[Música]
hola muy buenos días
feliz de estar de nuevo en esta querida
tierra y en realidad el título que
ustedes vieron ahí en la portadilla no
es exactamente lo que voy a conversar
pero tiene mucho que relacionarse mi
título más exacto sería quizás grandes
pensadores y estoy segura que usted en
este minuto van a decir esta señora a
hablarnos de platón de candelier de
leonardo davinci de stephen hawking pero
no
voy a hablar de unos fantásticos
pensadores que son los niños chiquitos
como le dicen aquí en costa rica los
párvulos le dirían en mi tierra y en
otros países no los niños desde
nacimiento hasta los 6 años y para ello
porque voy a hablar de ellos aparte de
ser obviamente mi campo de desempeño
porque
en este momento en américa latina y me
refiero a todos los países que no tienen
la posibilidad de conocer hay mucha
política pública respecto a los niños
pequeños hay establecimiento e
institucionalidad hay recursos no
suficiente aún porque no todos los niños
entre los 56 años tiene una oportunidad
de educación inicial no más o menos 60%
de los de 3 a 6 entonces todavía no es
un derecho la equidad todavía no es una
realidad para todos ellos pero hay algo
que me preocupa en especial que lo que
quiero conversar y reflexionar con usted
es la calidad de lo que está pasando en
los programas haciendo la observación
que siempre hay experiencias muy lindas
en todos los países pero nos interesa
mucho lo que pasa a veces a nivel
general no y donde a veces hay falta de
recursos o de ciertas facilidades para
que todo funcione bien y para eso voy a
pedirle a una maestra una maestra
mexicana
ella haga como un zoom y con esta
descripción que hace de una aula que
ustedes no están viendo que dice un
jardín de niños no es un lugar en que
los niños estén aprisionados en la sala
de clases con las manos inmóviles sobre
los pupitres las miradas vagando en el
espacio temerosos callados y tristes y
aquí viene una pregunta para ustedes
cuando creen que esta dama no está
maestra
habrá dicho habrá hecho esta observación
a ver quiénes creen más o menos hace 20
o 30 años a ver levanten en manos no
casi nada
unai a quienes consideran que hace medio
siglo atrás
nadie hace un siglo
cuando creen entonces que lo digamos
bueno algunas manos adelantadas en
realidad esto lo dijo esta maestra y
fíjense a la fecha mil 922 o sea en
américa latina no habían más de en cada
país 10 20 30 50 100 jardines infantiles
y ellas estaban alarmando no de que no
estaba bien lo que estaba pasando que
había muchas presiones para que esto se
convirtiera como ya vamos a ver en una
pequeña escuelita porque estas maestras
como la gran carmen lyra aquí no iban
denunciando esta situación ahí porque
todas ellas se habían formado
en europa con grandes maestros con la
literatura de esa época y tenían una muy
clara concepción que el niño tenía que
tener una educación activa como decía
dani recién donde fuera protagonista
esos aprendizajes con autonomía libertad
como ustedes ven en esa imagen
ustedes ven esa foto de mil 926 tan
todos los niños haciendo cosas distintas
con distintos materiales su trabajo
cuelgan por todas partes los de ellos no
los de la adulto
eso era el conocimiento que ellas tenían
y les alarmaba lo que pasaba el problema
de esta
avancemos un siglo no que un siglo
después esto es lo que vemos actualmente
en muchos lugares
desafortunadamente habría que decir la
salita como diría el gran pablo freire
la escuela bancaria un niño detrás del
otro papel lápiz falta de movimiento
falta de creatividad la típica figura
para colorear como si eso fuera lo
fundamental de la educación de la
primera infancia y sobre todo niños muy
aburridos y que se desarrollan poco
y esto por supuesto que no nos puede
alegrar a nadie y la pregunta sería esa
porque está mal esto después de un siglo
bueno y uno porque no estamos aplicando
el fantástico conocimiento que
actualmente tenemos la tecnología y en
la tarde va a hablar de neurociencias
también y las neuroimágenes nos muestran
lo que pasa en el cerebro infantil que
es muy plástico
un cerebro en una persona porque no hay
que tomar estos cerebros como aparente
como si tuvieran vida como algunos lo
plantean no un niño en el fondo o una
niña en que están en un mundo en un
mundo de interacciones y eso va creando
que sus neuronas van entrando en
conexiones y se va armando una
arquitectura cerebral que es la que
sostiene todo tipo de aprendizaje y
ustedes ven ahí desde el nacimiento y
cómo van proliferando pero en la medida
que este bebé tiene ciertas experiencias
y ciertos ambientes y cuáles son ellas
para empezar amor sin amor nadie crece y
menos un bebé
ausencia de estrés está comprobadísimo
que el estrés mata neuronas ojo con eso
piensen cómo vivimos nosotros cómo vive
la sociedad cómo vivimos los maestros no
entonces si estas dos fórmulas amor y
estrés no están qué problema y ustedes
vienen de aquí que hay dos cerebros
cortados con toda esta tecnología el de
el que está acá con vastas zonas negras
es un cerebro de un niño que no ha
tenido estos elementos ni un ambiente
enriquecido porque eso se llama un
ambiente enriquecido el amor falta de
estrés y oportunidades para hacer
explorar este mundo desde su ser
infantil en cambio el otro es la misma
situación en un niño que ha tenido todos
estos ingredientes que estamos señalando
entonces estamos perdiendo este
maravilloso potencial que tienen los
bebés
desde que nacen incluso antes
por eso es que si revisamos un poco de
la bibliografía actual vamos a encontrar
trabajos de investigaciones muy serias
como este libro que les recomiendo no de
una psicóloga estadounidense de la
universidad de berkeley
miren el título el bebé filosófico
y porque esto porque ella señala que el
bebé más que este mundo de plásticos que
los llenamos a veces de móviles comprado
no y otras cosas así lo que está
haciendo es conociendo el mundo de las
personas y haciendo de una teoría
práctica sobre esas personas
estaba la voz de la mamá que la va a
conocido antes que nazca ya después
obviamente se le hace evidente hay otra
quizás papá de los abuelos como lo tocan
que hacen con él qué extraño hay adultos
que se le acercan otros que son
reticentes va tratando de comprender y
haciendo esta teoría del mundo en las
relaciones humanas
esa es una de las tantas investigaciones
que nos muestra el fantástico potencial
de los bebés y además una segunda razón
porque hoy día un siglo después está mal
que estemos haciendo ciertas cosas no
con los niños es porque estos niños son
fantásticos cómo se ven ahí no un bebé
que está incluso en una posición un poco
incómoda pero hay tres objetos y vean
ustedes ese gesto maravilloso de mirar
uno el otro y el otro iba a tomar uno
por las razones más insospechadas no las
sabremos pero este es un ser curioso no
activo y que quiere también tener la
posibilidad de elegir habitualmente le
pasamos un sonajero no es como si esa
fuera la gracia y después queremos
ciudadanos que sepan elegir bien
entonces o jóvenes entonces esa
iniciativa la tiene al ser humano es de
que nace por la maravilla que es el ser
humano
y esas son las oportunidades que hay que
ver dar en estos ambientes enriquecidos
una tercera razón porque no estamos bien
es porque estamos desfasados en el
tiempo mientras tenemos a nuestros niños
repitiendo como lorito del 1 al 40
haciendo rayitas sin sentido
la escuelita tradicional a ellos les
interesa el pasado y son especialistas
en dinosaurios y seres prehistóricos de
toda índole del futuro ellos les
interesa mucho del fondo del mar de lo
que hay en todo el mundo que hoy día lo
tienen como acceso ciudadanos locales
siempre vencerlo y planetarios y ustedes
ven ahí en la imagen dos niños son
escuelas públicas en chile no uno
haciendo artefactos con cosas tan
sencillas como las que ven mangueras
alambres con o dos de plástico haciendo
un aparato un ingenio como decía el gran
leonardo da vinci no nosotros están
haciendo un experimento de energía solar
viendo dónde se calienta realmente el
agua bajo qué condiciones mejor los
niños de hoy son
de medioambientalistas ya que estamos en
este país que favorece tanto esos
aspectos entonces no los temas de hoy no
están llegando a los niños están
haciendo pintando dos patitos amarillos
del mismo color con la figura
estereotipada como si esa fuera la
realidad cuando es la etapa como ya
vamos a ver que ellos tienen que
aprender con cosas concretas reales y
significativas
entonces una buena educación inicial
vamos a señalar unos cinco aspectos
cruciales que hay que tener presente
primero concepto potente de niño nada de
imágenes limitadas pero desde su ser de
niño no es sobre estimulación es creer
que el niño puede hacer cosas no y para
eso concepto protagonista es sujeto y un
ejemplo aquí hay una hay un libro que se
llama la abc de los niños que está hecho
por la junta nacional de jardines
infantiles en mi país que le preguntaron
a niños de todo chile conceptos y
términos para que ellos los definieron
ya que hay tres para ver este
pensamiento estos pequeños pensadores no
hay ese cordillera donde se junta el sol
con la tierra díganme si no es un poema
no
duda preguntar y pensar una cosa que no
sé y miren en la cara de duda que tiene
fantástica
y bueno en la definición de identidad
cultural que no debemos perder nunca a
los latinoamericanos chile que es chile
soy yo qué fantástico que lo diga yo sé
un niño no bueno vamos viendo otro de
estos tips que no hay que olvidar
el niño mientras más chiquitito tiene
que tener experiencias concretas como
estamos viendo ahí con los animales con
las plantas tienen que hablar oler
gustar tomarle el peso la temperatura
eso tiene que hacer no texturas la
tierra como está ahí ojo los bebés están
llenos de celular en este minuto uno en
cualquier lugar ve que está este niño le
ponen un celular casi ahí para dejarlo
cierto dormido no ensimismado con este
aparato está perdiendo oportunidades de
todo tipo de desarrollarse afectivas
motoras cognitivas etcétera tienen que
salir de diversidades recién los jóvenes
tienes que salir pero los que primero
tienen que estar en contacto con la
realidad son los bebés y los niños
pequeños y esa es la forma de aprender
de ellos del mundo
otra otra sugerencia que nunca debe
faltar no es el juego el juego pero el
verdadero juego con todo respeto no el
juego chantajeado
el juego que tiene un fin en sí de
placer quien lo inicia el niño quien lo
va descubriendo y dice yo soy un
astronauta y aquí voy a jugar con mi
amiguito y vamos a ir a un planeta ese
juego no el juego de vamos a contar de
130 eso no es juego
y usamos mucho eso ahí como como
elemento jugar por jugar
transformar tiene que ser un un
cambiador de cosas el ser humano
construyó cultura a partir de elementos
que se le dieron de todo índole ese niño
que no hace nada que juega con cosas
siempre dadas fijas está perdiendo
también muchas oportunidades la
imaginación lugar a la imaginación a la
creación de todo tipo con toda la forma
jamás debe faltar eso en las
experiencias de educación inicial y el
pensar pensar que estás siempre pensando
haciendo son niños prácticos no es que
cuando decimos grandes pensadores se nos
van a colocar así a pensar en lo hace
haciendo cosas esos son elementos claves
que no deberían faltar para una buena
educación inicial y terminó con un
pensamiento
nuestras maestras y premios primera
premio nobel de literatura gabriela
mistral que espero que la sientan como
de todos porque así fue que esta cita
fijense ahora no hay conferencia
educación inicial en el mundo yo lo ha
visto en todos los idiomas no y dice el
futuro en los niños es siempre hoy
mañana será tarde generalmente como
estamos todos tan apurados que se reduce
en el niño es ahora así lo he visto
reducidos pero fíjense que ella lo dijo
en mil 944 o sea hace 70 80 años atrás
no y todavía se siguen denunciando que
hay que hacer cosas a favor de los niños
verdadero educación y seguimos y
seguimos y no lo hacemos no entonces ya
es tiempo que esto se haga realidad y lo
que tantos maravillosos educadores y
otros profesionales han hecho pero esto
no es tarea sólo de los maestros esto
estaría en primer lugar de la familia de
las instituciones
de la sociedad entera que tiene que
entender las características de
desarrollo de aprendizaje del niño
pequeño y todos colaborar porque el niño
aprende de todo en todas partes esa
tarea para que tengamos una generación
de latinoamericanos cada vez mejor más
humanos respetuoso del medio ambiente
con todos los valores importantes claro
imaginativo creativo y todo lo que
deseamos lo que es realmente ser humano
es la gran invitación a que sigamos
trabajando por ello pero quizás
apoyándonos un poco más y haciéndolo
cada día mejor esa es la invitación que
les quería dejar muchas gracias por su
atención
[Aplausos]
[Música]